exactement bah oui cette bière le relief
vous l'avais appelé comme ça en hommage
à votre département et justement au fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas d'autres brasseries
finalement ici ouais ouais du coup bah
c'est vrai qu'à cette époque on n'essaie
pas vraiment leurs lots le relief
c'étaient les beaucerons les percherons
mais le terme eurélienne n'était
vraiment pas utiliser beaucoup plus
maintenant c'est vrai je les dis à votre
oeil a salué la pression sans vouloir
faire de jolis mots puisque non mais on
connaît un peu ambassadeur de ce nom là
maintenant c'est vrai que les gens font
facilement la référence entre le relief
et la bière et du coup on doit bas de
toujours montrer peu patte blanche
d'avoir un produit très bonne qualité on
est on est vraiment attendu au tournant
parce que
en cinq ans un plan simple on s'impose
en mec de leur présenter les instruments
et de le rendre fier du coup déjà je
pense que ce qu'il ya autour de nous de
vous rendre très très fier parce que
parce que c'est ça cette immense
bâtiment expire en 2013 ces gros danger
pour nous parler mais du coup le
résultat le résultat il est là il ya ces
immenses cuves autour de noms
voilà y'a quoi dans ce que via votre
bière qui est en train de finir de 2 le
process de fabrication d'un d'une bière
c'est ça va être huit à dix semaines
voilà pour vous bon pour nous voilà
c'est peut-être que vous vous avez
choisi une méthode artisanale pour une
méthode de travail artisanal vous voulez
rester là dessus on travaille vraiment
la manière la plus traditionnelle
possible avec les matières nobles
on n'utilise que les matières premières
essentielles à la fabrication du produit
donc après dans les tubes il va y avoir
deux étapes la première ça va être la
fermentation a donc tout bas ça va durer
6 8 10 12 jours c'est à dire qu'on va
faire des prélèvements au fur et à
mesure de cette fermentation pour
vraiment inspecter la densité de notre
produit oui et on mettra après en garde
et sept gardes pareil elle va durer
quinze jours trois semaines un mois cinq
semaines c'est son temps d'affinage
c'est là où elle va mature et c'est à
partir de 2,7 de cette maturité de sept
affinage permettra après nos produits en
bouteille
mettez vous avez décidé justement de lui
laisser le temps à votre bière c'est
vous qui avez décidé que ce serait
c'est ce qu'on appelle une bière de
garde en fait mais c'est vrai c'est ça
alors bas on décide en fait deux
au départ dans un protocole de mettre un
certain nombre de semaines de garde
après c'est ça va être le travail du
brasseur de faire ces prélèvements
régulièrement pour voir la qualité de
son produit est de déterminer ses
produits il est prêt ou s'il faut le
laisser en garde un peu plus longtemps
et je crois qu'en plus la particularité
de voix bien c'est finalement la
fermentation se termine en bouteille
c'est ça c'est ça alors ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'art fermentation de la
bière donc s'être fermentation donc on
part d'un produit qui est quasi mon plat
au moment de l'embouteillage on va
utiliser bas la présence des levures qui
sont toujours vivantes et et qui
demandent qu'à se multiplier en fait
dans la bouteille ont valeur intégrée un
petit peu de sucre et donc par la
température ou par la refermentation on
va obtenir donc bah le gaz naturel du
produit et selon vous est ce que votre
orge en tout cas est ce que veut
céréales est ce que c'est ça qui va
donner la typicité de beaube bière est
ce que ces deux là dessus vous
travaillez horse en fait partie je dis
souvent c'est un autre métier encore qui
vient se greffer au métier d'agriculteur
au métier de brasseur puisqu'il faut
maîtriser après derrière la technique de
l'orge souvent
un brasseur va acheter donc de l'orge
une malterie qui a déjà des
caractéristiques techniques assez
commune nous on va avoir pratiquement 1
mélusine un millésime par monnaie
puisque du coup c'est par rapport à ce
millésime qu'il va falloir adapter notre
recette ya pas deux mais elle n'est pas
mélangée avec une autre or jouent avec
un autre mâle ton par vraiment du malt
de l'année et après faut qu'on se en
gros faut qu'on se débrouille avec avec
ses caractéristiques et surtout vous
vous débrouillez pour pouvoir semer en
temps et en heure et lormont dit ouais
c'est pas gagné là on est en plein
dedans justement je le taquine un petit
peu parce que justement il est vrai bien
sourit mais les conditions climatiques
ne l'êtes pas beaucoup il faudrait 41
termine c'est possible j'avais mis
qu'elle fasse en sorte que ce soit un
petit peu plus sec pour pouvoir aller
dans les chances mais justement l'orge
pour qu'on ait de belles bien l'année
prochaine
il faut croiser les doigts vous l'avez
vu à eloïse pour le moment c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas trop de soleil mais on
espère que ça va venir ces prochains
jours